- Les gars, l'appel !
- À mon commandement, garde à vous ! Repos.
- Messieurs, bonjour.
Donc, tout fonctionne à bord,
on appareille à 10 heures, on rallie le bord,
on ferme le panneau, on lance le dard, PCV,
poste général à 9 heures et demie.
- Et comme hier, vous donnez tout ce que vous avez donné,
et ça va bien se passer. Bon courage à tous.
- À l'appel de votre nom, vous rejoignez le bord.
- Capitaine CORVETTE Julien.
- C'est parti, c'est parti.
C'est la première fois pour de vrai,
donc premier embarquement officiel.
J'ai bien dormi, contrairement à ce que je pensais.
Quand on est bien fatigué après la journée qu'on a passée hier,
on dort très, très bien.
Les 70 membres de l'équipage sont à bord.
- C'est bon.
Alexis a 31 ans. Il est lieutenant de vaisseau,
mais il est aussi ingénieur en énergie atomique
et responsable du réacteur nucléaire.
Son bureau à lui, c'est une salle des machines
qui se trouve derrière ce sas de sécurité.
- Donc là, on est dans le sas d'accès
à toute la zone machine à l'arrière.
Donc, sur la deuxième moitié du sous-marin,
il y a à peu près un tiers de l'équipage qui travaille.
Et c'est là qu'on a notre petite centrale nucléaire
qui nous permet de faire avancer le sous-marin,
de produire l'électricité qu'on utilise partout
dans le sous-marin et aussi de produire l'eau
qui va nous servir, entre autres,
pour boire ou pour nous laver.
C'est une zone qui est interdite au grand public.
Ça conditionne tout le fonctionnement du sous-marin,
sa vitesse, tout ce qu'il peut faire,
donc on ne peut pas la montrer.
J'y vais sans vous.
- C'est confidentiel ?
- C'est confidentiel.
Dehors, dans le massif, la partie haute du sous-marin,
Juste s'assure du bon fonctionnement des ballasts.
Les réservoirs qui, en se remplissant d'eau,
lestent le sous-marin et lui permettent de plonger.
- Il faut vérifier que le bateau est capable de plonger
en ouvrant les purges. Après, je vérifierai
qu'il est capable de remonter en chassant.
- En fait, un sous-marin, ça ne part pas comme ça
avec un tour de clé ?
- Non.
C'est un peu plus long qu'une deux chevaux.
Moi, ça fait plus de dix ans que je suis dans les sous-marins.
Et donc je travaille pour ça.
Et j'ai réussi des qualifications et autres.
À chaque fois, on est remis en cause,
donc il y a quand même une bonne dose d'humilité.
Mais c'est quand même une fierté d'arriver
à progresser dans cette voie.
Et il y a une fierté collective parce que
moi, tout seul, je ne fais pas partir le sous-marin.
Donc forcément, tout le monde à bord est important.
Chacun a son rôle. Même le jeune embarqué qui est ici,
tout ce qu'il a appris, c'est peut-être lui qui,
dans quelques heures, va découvrir quelque chose
et va nous sauver tous.
En quelques minutes, le bateau sort du port,
escorté par une vedette de la gendarmerie maritime,
chargée d'éloigner les bateaux de plaisance.
Par tradition et pour conjurer le sort,
les militaires saluent le monument des sous-mariniers
disparus en mer à la sortie de la rade.
Prochaine étape, la plongée.